this is a production of cornell
university
uh
thanks for the invitation i'm very
looking forward to uh
share some uh thoughts and and what i'm
doing on what i'm thinking to
do at the university of florida and
thanks for the opportunities to to
collaborate
so maybe a highlight of what i'm trying
to
do and develop here at uf based on what
i
done in in cortez and build on on that
foundation
is to reimagine agricultural solution to
climate change uh the narrative today is
the the other way around but i think
there's a huge opportunity and it's
quite imperative that we do of course
i'm not going to be the one to do it
hopefully i can make a contribution to
it
now more specifically
i'm looking forward to develop and apply
breathing technologies uf brings a lot
of opportunities think about
i think we have like 50 breeding
programs
that will expose challenges and help us
develop methods and create opportunities
to think about the circular bioeconomy
there's a tremendous opportunity here to
work with edge group on the circa
project and i'm looking forward to that
work uh too
and finally something that
cut me a little bit by surprise i was
behind the
iron curtains uh
and it'll be the detach on on uh
climate change breeding if you will and
more focus on the shorter term
and when i start uh
doing some research about where we were
at
i found i think there's a
big opportunity here to
uh inform
and collaborate to put the framework
together and how we're going to do it
it was surprising that
um
the whole or the the the opportunity i
think uh we have in front of us i think
the narrative
was mainly driven by agronomies rather
than breeders so anyways i think it is
an opportunity to
have an impact not only as florida but
as a community of breeders in particular
working with climatologists
so i'd like to start with what problem
we are trying to solve we're talking
about climate change and circular
economies
and to to me is this high throughput
high externalities agriculture is is
known
it's never been too sustainable but it's
certainly not sustainable right now
an eye opener for me
was to read a report from rockefeller
foundation
and
the
two numbers that are really striking
are
the
agricultural economy generated trillion
dollars in value
and generates two trillion dollar costs
in externalities tied to
human health
and environmental impacts
so today the way this high throughput
high externalities agriculture is
working is generating more problems and
itself of course we need to eat so it's
a kind of a a
difficult problem we have enhanced
however i don't think there's
a limitation to to change how things are
done and i will build a little bit of
how we got here based on this grain
based example what we show
we would see in this graph
is the trajectory about 100 years of
class of breeding
where
for most part
it was all about
keeping them
hybrid standing mechanization increasing
the throughput of the system right that
was the double cross area put keep those
plants standing plant more ecos
and
leverage the capacity of corn to
deliver on that photosynthesis in the
single cross area is
sort of
synchronous with
the increasing use of fertilizers
irrigation essentially we're breeding
for
plants that were transforming
increasingly amounts of inputs into into
outputs without regard to what was going
on
uh with the aquifers and and what not in
the the last part of the biotech
i think we start getting into that
circularity by reducing the amount of
pesticides but still it was in the same
path to create
these machines that transform more and
more inputs into output it wasn't until
that we
work with the ecomax drought taller and
looking at increasing use efficiencies
of water
and resources that
you can start seeing an incipient or the
onset of
uh some circularity thinking uh in
that is built with into the uh breathing
programs
so by large the
breeding has happened without
regards to
[Music]
externalities if you will it was pretty
much one-dimensional
so an alternative paradigm that is quite
appealing is the circularity i came
familiar with this as macarthur
foundation start providing it's really
intuitive this nice cartoon get
everything within the cities recycling
uh as a concept is great i think the the
principles
will help to bring
to practice some of the sustainability
ambitions the
uh industrial ecology framework uh is
quite practical in terms of engineering
something that
it's kind of hitting and always i wonder
what uh
why was in there you know is the
intention of the macarthur foundation i
think healthy food product is always a
good thing but it wasn't clear to me
how that has anything to do with
circularity and to understand i start uh
scribbling a little bit and how the
different elements
are at very high level uh relate to each
other between climate change human
health and agriculture essentially to
understand to myself how these things
connect to each other
and
the the clear
outcome of this sort of a
system
that
reinforces itself is if we
keep in this path of high externalities
agriculture we are going to have impacts
on the climate it will have a negative
impact on agriculture and this is going
to spiral down
same thing with the externalities
poor human health reduce productivity so
what do we do we put more inputs to
compensate for lower inefficiency in
agriculture and we keep things making
things worse and worse so this thing is
going to spiral down until we break the
whole system
so how
how you sort of uh disrupt this uh
vicious cycle and here is where i
it's sort of a
click that sort of little corner in
yellow that you barely see in terms of
human health and diet is diet is the
signal between what humans want from
agriculture to deliver if we want uh
cheap beef uh produced with large
quantities from ogallala nebraska is
going to continue to produce corn that's
that that's what society is demanding
so diet essentially is at the core of
how we're going to signal agriculture to
shift
and
how we're going to think about
agriculture in different processes in
terms of whether it's ethanol or ethanol
or
beef produced with a recent amount of
protein from different sources or
plant-based agriculture i don't know
what is the answer but certainly what
connects and what can disrupt this cycle
is this diet as we shift
the purpose of agricultural objectives
and how we reshape the bioeconomy so my
work in hypotheses is plant breeding
emergency engineering and certainly
artificial intelligence is
mouth full worth of words hopefully will
become more more clear what i'm thinking
throughout the presentation
is what is going to
enable to create the products to
reimagine the agriculture essentially
prime breeding is what if diet is going
to signal agriculture what to do plant
breeding is that mechanism or methods we
have to create the products for the
farmers to pre-engage or re-imagine this
agriculture and make it a reality
so with that then the question is how we
are going to transition let's assume we
can do it breathing we know how how we
operate how we go from linear to
circular agriculture and to me has a lot
to do
with being really deliberate and to be
deliberate we need to engage design
thinking
and going back to my first statement of
we were fueling
inputs to corn and ask for outputs and
increasing amount of outputs without
concern of water quality what
what that is representing that g by m
technology and multiple traits we were
100 years of one dimension essentially
is
in in produce and vegetables maybe
quality and corn may be ill maybe
morphology physiology if you want to
start getting into more efficiencies in
terms of how we are going to increase
yields but nobody pay attention into
that
selection index so what was the nitrogen
emissions easy water quality how much
water were we pumping from the ogallala
or are we or are we sequestering carbon
or what are the emissions
so to
to transition to this circular
bioeconomy we need to start thinking
differently on how we're going to
[Music]
create these selection indices if you
will and how you're going to generate
information we can't really wait 30
years for a data point to come back on
what is the carbon sequestration so here
is where i think modeling and simulation
it can become quite critical same thing
with nitrogen
a little bit less on on water so
essentially we need to empower develop
methods
to
empower decision makers to approach some
of these dilemmas sometimes his water
and productivity is going to trade
against each other so we need to make a
decision
the other is a shifting mindset
where we try to put simple solutions or
sim provide simple answers instead of
thinking about simple methods to manage
complex systems think about regulations
and nitrogen papers recently published
on how you're going to tax nitrogen
that's a really bad idea everybody is
going to make the wrong decision instead
of creating frameworks that enable
everybody to make the right decision yet
attain the goals of reducing
externalities
so
how a crop design framework might start
looking like or what are the components
that at least i think we need to bring
to place the first one is start thinking
about processes rather than states and
and how we think about the phenomics
and all the engineering that goes with
it to start phenotyping
or conduct phenotyping that leads to
enhanced scientific and genomic
understanding because that is what is
going it is going to enable us to
predict not only yield but all these
other consequences at the system level
of if you make a decision
a breeding decision how much is going to
impact heal what are used what are your
sufficiencies nitrogen carbon
sequestration you can run a simulation
for 30 years for that matter so we
empower the decision maker and provide
information that otherwise is not going
to be available to them certainly not
today
and what brings everything together i is
in my mind this artificial intelligence
and i will elaborate a little bit more
on that
the other piece if we're going to design
things we need to measure success
and to me
a very simple way to measure success is
through genetic gain
but the very single identity here is
that genetic gain has to be greater or
equal to demand from the growing
population whatever that is coming from
and
while i'm not ready to put a calculated
time derivative here i think this
identity is quite useful to think about
what is the
uh problem with increasing genetic gain
and
the equation right there and the
heritability is a function of the
variation for genetic variation
and divided by
the g by interactions and the errors
again i i know some breeders in the
audience this is trivial hopefully uh
for the climatologists is something that
become a little bit more useful to
understand that the environment is one
of the problems as we interact with the
genetics to
hamper our abilities to
make a genetic improvement and improve
crops
so this is a an example that we can go
through that g by e it's a
it's an emergent property that depends
not only on the genetics but on the
expression of the physiology and the
range of environments that constitute
that population of environments we are
trying to breed for
on the left you would see
uh hopefully a number of
in the vertical the number of different
types of g by starting on the top with
no g by e this is very simple
representation you have two environments
on the x yield or any property on the y
parallel lines means you're making
gender gain you
whatever decision you make is the right
one whatever those experiments you
conducted
the second from the top you'd see that
is heterogeneous your variances so yeah
there's a g by e but doesn't affect your
decisions essentially
in one environment one hybrid is going
to eat more than in the other
the lack of correlation is here the the
devil
that we need to fight all the time
and when things combined that the things
can get pretty ugly and that's probably
some of the throughout uh
examples uh we can elaborate so if we
start on the figure on the center look
at the bottom we have a ill scale
uh just want to bring to attention this
was created by randy clark this was
susan's student
from from cornell and the y is each of
different traits different colors here
it will represent
a trait
and on the y will tell you how important
that trait is to explain variation
among different hybrids as these
different levels of yield
so if you take this yellow
trait
is silk emergence rate how it responds
to water deficit
you can see if environment one
is at let's say 600 gram per square
meter probably flowering stress a hybrid
that has a good silk emergence how yield
the one that it doesn't explain a lot of
variation
and as you increase the water
availability that trade become less
relevant will explain less variation
become even
inconsequential at 1200
gram per square meter environment one
environment two variation in that trade
will lead to
uh
heterogeneous ovarian gye but certainly
the decisions that you're going to make
is not going to be affected think about
the other one is cannot be size canopy
size is related to light interception
carbon assimilation transpiration this
is what's been driving yield in corn for
the last hundred years in terms of
either plant or a canopy level
so
if environment two is an irrigated in
nebraska big plants consume a lot of
water it's a great idea
you your pivot breaks your environment
too becomes environment one
big plants consume a lot of water enter
into drought and those plants will crash
a lot of the aqua max drought material
has some of these characteristics of
conserving water
to prevent that crash so
this trade depending on the environment
you are looking at it will generate that
lack of correlation and will trade if
you will
the performance on one environment
against each other and if you combine
these two trades the sig and the canopy
size for example in environment two you
have a big plant with poor sleeping
abilities it's going to have
heterogeneous variancy because it's
going to crash really miserable and you
will see some pictures
throughout the presentation uh
and of course he's not going to get the
series out
and on the other end he is going to
produce yields but not as much as
it could so again depending on the trade
combination depending on which
environments are you sampling
you are going to see different patterns
of gba
so what
the argument to my argument is that
enable to
manage this complexity and emerging
patterns particularly in genotype by
environment interactions
and think about the environment to put
the management there too we need some
biostatistical machinery to be able to
predict this
while this appealing to to think about
deep learning and some of these tools i
think by harnessing the scientific
understanding and coding everything we
know
and we call that symbolic ai
with the statistical learning
capabilities whether it's deep learning
or something else call it statistical
learning in general as a
form of sub-symbolic ai we are going to
make my progress there are some papers
published recently they called the
futurist hybrid
carla gomez applied this to material
sciences we got to the same
path through looking at genotype by
environment interaction so you can start
seeing from remote in material science
genetics we are sort of coming to the
same conclusion that
harnessing scientific understanding is a
good idea rather than put data in a
black box and hope for the best
so if you think about the phenotype uh
plant phenotype crop phenotype as a
function and t is for total so that's
your theory of everything you can break
this in what we know that's your
scientific understanding what you don't
know and you would like to figure out at
some point in time we didn't know about
photosynthesis now we know so
essentially you start moving knowledge
from or what you uncover from age and
put it into q as a detective
uh
this is pretty trivial but i just want
to
make it formal uh how
crop models map into this skew this is
what we this is what we know essentially
it's out of the ft which is the world
that's around us
and crop models as this introduction are
formal systems that represent the
knowledge and physiology environmental
science and more important is a
cognitive model because you represent
the topology of the network
how elements or
components of the system are causally
related to each other
just
you probably re
you might have hear
me talk about this
other times
but remember this network remember this
cognitive model because you will see how
when you start combining symbolic and
sub-symbolic ai the same way
genomic prediction borrow information
genetic information to make prediction
about individuals that were not tested
we can borrow biologic we can borrow
information through these biological
networks
to make predictions for even genetics
that are not
were tested so it's a different way to
borrow information to improve the
prediction of algorithms
so that's called crop models or symbolic
ai
do these models work
and
one way at least is important to me is
the ability to predict importance of
trade but certainly emerging patterns of
g by e you you saw the the work done by
randy this is a different example now at
a larger scale
we start doing these experiments on
limited transformational conductance
response to
humidity
with tom sinclair
to ask the question is the trade like
this even remotely relevant to undertake
further research and it was and that
motivates a lot of investments within
cortez
the
what you can see here
think about look at the regions a and b
on the corn below the western corn belt
this genotype one out eel genotype two
in dry years panel c or even wet ears on
panel a drought is pretty generic and
generalized there with some exemptions
even even think about if there's no g by
e or maybe some heterogeneous variances
problem comes when you start going to
region c
where in dry years is going to
outperform genotype 2
and now you have the crossover
interaction and lack of correlation so a
relatively simple model
and a trait that even at this point but
at this point the video was a
hypothetical one we
were able to start detecting what were
maybe the consequences and what were the
regions where these traits may be used
so this is a part of the symbolic ai
that make us comfortable yes these
models can capture a lot of behavior
based on our scientific understanding
even a scientific speculation of
functioning traits
so now that you have these crop growth
models would like to
bring to your attention is there
things that we know within the crop mole
like use efficiency in photosynthesis
and some things that we know may maybe
partitioning but
we either want to don't want to measure
or
it will be difficult or too expensive
and we want to estimate so think about
these crop growth models we have a
vector of known parameters unknown
parameters we want to estimate and of
course you have the forcing through
environments and management
just want to use that to
introduce this integration of symbolic
and sub-symbolic ai through cgmwgp which
is crop growth molecular genome
prediction
think about the crop growth model as a
way to an algorithm to generate data not
not field data it would be in silicon
data and that would be a function again
of a vector of parameters and a forcing
and the whole genome prediction
is going to be an algorithm that in this
case is
it's a linear mixed model the animal
modeling more specific will generate the
ability to use marker or genetic
competitive information depending on
what you're using
to estimate a mean and the vector of
let's say marker value so essentially
think about you have now a function that
can tell you some to tell you something
that you can use to predict any
particular trait in this case y would be
the the rue if you measure your train
you'll be able to estimate that number
and you can use with within the crop
growth model so when you combine these
two things you can put together a
likelihood function which gives you that
probability of given the data that
either generated observed uh what is the
what is the probability of the the
markers given the data observed
he said the other way around sorry in
the consecutive base theorem the
posterior will give you the probability
of the
estimated
marker effects given the data you have
and more important i think that we often
we don't say explicitly
is conditioned upon also of everything
else you assume remain constant for
example if you have a very complex crop
growth model you may have 40 parameters
your estimating iues essentially is one
out of 40 that this
uh posterior distribution of rue or
marker effects for eel and rue if you
will
is going to be conditioned upon
all that in from all
the parameters you assume the remain
constant
again
i think this is important to
to bring to your attention as you start
thinking about using some of these
methodologies
so an abc approximation computation
study i would i just use this
in class here at university of florida
to teach plant breeding students i use a
tight private distribution for radiation
use efficiency conversion of
light into carbon uh so it converges uh
within a reasonable amount of time
so think about we sample this prior
we use the
linear mix model
to estimate genomic breathing value
then we with those genomic breathing
values we simulate
multi-environment trial
with parameters we want to we know plus
the rue given a set of environments that
we sample we calculate our simulated
data set we compare the true with the
observation with the simulations if that
delta is acceptable we keep it to
build our posterior distribution
and estimate the marker effect if not we
discard and we continue going through
this process over and over this is
slightly different from what we done
with with frank techno in the past but i
i like the way it connects more
explicitly and clear the crop growth
model with
genomic prediction
so now we can run a simulation
to see if we can recover the truth here
what i created is a map of yield
for a very simple multi-environment
trial of two environment
each point is a different genotype
that the only difference it has
with respect to all the other genotypes
is the value of rue and you can see
there's a bifurcation at about iue um
larger than
1.45
you can see that there's a split in the
behavior in environment one and two many
times this environment
uh
when we use them in for a gibla
we just combine them make a prediction
so
we don't have the capability to
discriminate unless we have a very
compelling evidence that these are two
environments to belong to different
environment types
so when we run the
[Music]
the algorithm i just described you can
see that we can recover the
rue
uh very nicely the posterior you can
compare the posterior and the pryor
but we also you can see here is there's
a shrinkage so you can see the true rue
which we defined
in in our multi-environment trial run
between 1.2 and 2
and the predictions is
1.5165 and this is because of the
shrinking that it was imposed when we
calculated
the linear mix model
but this is uh import or is this
important to make prediction and run
hybrids and what you can see here is is
not essentially the algorithm shrunk the
range of rue but still
in a condensed manner we're able to
estimate all the rankings accurately for
both environment and what's important to
note here in contrast to the g lab we
would not calculate this value for one
environment and the other one we just
feed all the information and the
algorithm figure out how to is going to
partition that information environmental
and genetic to make the predictions and
estimate the performance for the two
different environment types
when you don't know the environments
these become actually quite powerful
so does it work and rather than
tell you exactly what we did in
different
[Music]
cases certainly i'm more happy to refer
to different papers so you see exactly
how the experiments were conducted i
would like to take the opportunity to
reflect on how i would do it if i need
to
apply this to a cassava in other places
or sorghum or how i'm thinking about
applying this in eggplants or other
vegetable crops for which we don't have
10 years
ahead of us to develop crop models or
the funding or the scale of a breeding
program for mace at industrial scale
and to me the the algorithm is pretty
simple start very simple models it is
that have doesn't have to be over
complicated
but
look at
combining processes for which you have
well-defined constants
and
focus on the traits that
the breather is telling you that is
varying on the genoplasm or look at the
hypothesis that you can formulate about
what traits may be vary in the general
plasma
then you can leverage existing data sets
there are a number of breathing trials
of high quality there are a lot of
physiological studies can be conducted
and with the innovation framework you
can accommodate all this uncertainty
and then
develop your cgmw gp3 iteration just
don't wait until you get the perfect
crop model or genomic prediction
algorithm start iterating and ask the
question whether
the
genotype by environment by management
system of your interest is this
technology and methodology can give you
an edge
relative to alternative approaches and
then you start applying within the
breathing program because that's where
it's going to surface all the
opportunities to improve and start
guiding
the development of the method and of
course
all this is hypothetical up to this
point so you can start designing
experiments and put your effort and
resources to test this hypothesis rather
than to stop building
part of the background
so in
as i mentioned if you want to
learn about exactly the the methods and
how we did it
we published this
a lot of these with christine
dippenbrook another graduate from
cornell
when we were in
both corteba this particular case was a
very large dial half dialed
[Music]
experiment include about 2300 hybrids
uh i think which is just one tester in
this particular case
and run um about 23 locations that
uh which evapotranspiration range for
about 800 to
here
below 400 millimeters so that tells you
a little bit about
the the range of environment and as you
uh
so in the in
in the image i create randy clark
created about the eel performance and
the different traits you can see on
these more harsher environments
the g by increases a lot of associated
with the silk elongation these are not
extreme environments where you expect
that nothing is going to work right
everything is dead so there's a sweet
spot on how this accuracy difference
between the crop molecular genome
prediction which is has that
biostatistical machinery to predict gye
uh compare against let's say
they a or any of the genomic algorithms
that does not have that machinery to
predict g by e
so you can see in well water environment
everything is water so it doesn't really
matter there's not a lot of g by e so
not surprising the accuracy difference
is very low i started pushing this to
more
stress environments where the g by e and
the trading between water carbon water
conservation and whatnot you saw a
couple of examples of that
with the limited transpiration the
silicon you can see any biostatistical
machinery that can capture that behavior
is going to have an edge over an
algorithm that it doesn't and this is
what you see in this figure as that gye
increases the accuracy difference
increases
this is a more recent
paper we put together
[Music]
that uses
a bigger data set uh less diverse i
think
i would say but include about 7 600
hybrids about six years of experiments
in in the corn belt the range of
evapotranspiration is its largest is
from 250 to 800 millimeters
and we
generate and this is an images for the
checks between total barrenness and
pretty much half full uh
years the the goal here was to advance
the methodology now to train this crop
growth small whole genome prediction not
not just on yield but how we started
utilizing other traits to improve the
predictive skill of the algorithm so
here
this complex figure let me take a few
minutes here to explain what you will
see in
figure a is the same figure you would
you might have seen in another paper so
i'll show you before essentially you
have the accuracy
of the
whole genome prediction algorithm for
yield train for yield and the accuracy
of the crop model whole genome
predictions essentially you have
a whole genome prediction without
an a component to predict g by e and
whole genome prediction with an addition
of machinery
the symbolic ai machinery to predict uh
g by e and not surprising particularly
look at the accuracy levels that we are
dealing with in here
anywhere between point
three and negative point three for the
whole genome prediction
by saying this particular case
there's a fair amount of gye in here you
can see that
by large most of the time when you add
the scientific understanding you
increase the predicted the prediction
accuracy
so now move to shed which is panel b
what we are trying to do here
and you need to read this panel slightly
different because we are trying to
predict shed using green ill information
and the accuracy of the wgp is
of course you can do that so what you
are doing is just providing a mesh
metric of what would be the
predictability if you have that shared
data
and if you look at the distribution of
all the points the accuracy of the cgm
wgp is pretty much centered around zero
it tells you it can't do it
it
it's just by chance it generates
accuracy of 0.3 and equally likely with
minus 0.03
but now move to the silk
so we are still training the algorithm
using grain yield data alone the
algorithm have no information to predict
silk
and
the expectation
based on wgp should do something that
maybe a mean around 0.3 or 0.4
but compared with the shed they see the
distribution of that accuracies for
silica certainly shifted relative to the
shed distribution
so what is happening here
is
the biological network that crop growth
model essentially is linking yield to
silk
to
kernel numbers so there's a path
and as i mentioned that
this scientific understanding helped you
build this causal relation and topology
so
they
call it symbolic sub-symbolic ai what is
doing is leveraging that topology of
that biological network to borrow
information from yield to be able to say
something about the silk in the genomic
prediction
algorithms what they're using is markers
and pedigree relationships to borrow
information
from the different relatives to make
predictions of something we didn't
observe in this particular case we
didn't observe silk but we are
predicting it borrowing information
which is encapsulated in that network
that biological network so think about
those two algorithms are using exactly
the same strategy to borrow information
to say something about a trait or a
relative that we have not tested or an
environment we have not tested
and now if you move to canons cannons
peria
it's a similar situation still borrowing
information probably spilled over from
silk
to
predict something about what's happening
in the canals per year you have a whole
genome prediction algorithm for kernels
per year without having to phenotype
canals per year
again the accuracy is not great but you
can see certainly a shift on that
distribution which is looks like
different from zero
i wish i tested that
so now you go to the panels on on the
lower set of panels now what we are
going to do is we are going to predict
green yield but we are going to use data
for grainy shed silks
uh all together we haven't used uh canos
per year data uh in in any of these
situations
so you can see that
green eel i think if you can do a good
job yet
now that we have shed and silk the
causality and these predictions are more
robust
for shed now that the algorithm has
information about shared has no problem
making that prediction you can see the
the shift in the clouds of points
either above the one to one line or at
the same level of the
wgp and same thing with the six
essentially it maintains that edge so
you can see the the point about the
one-to-one line but for all the other
points that they were not able to borrow
that information perhaps it was more
constitutive type of uh effect on
silking uh now is he's able to harness
that leverage that information of
phenotypic information and for channels
per year you can see a slight
improvement and this gives me to
a good segue that
this is an iterative mode building let
me re-emphasize what i told you before
we start with the simplest model you can
and you find your errors and you iterate
so here what
uh well what we've done
is again building with uh
another graduate i'm sorry
a graduate from grant helping us build
this uh phenotyping platform
and to test the hypothesis that the
error that we are seeing here in the
prediction of kernels per year is due to
lack of biological processing in the
model so
we we tested this we put it in the crop
mall we have a good handle on prediction
of canon number based on growth rate the
models can generate these emerging
patterns of behavior
so these hypotheses we can't really
reject it but doesn't seem to be the
favor of hypotheses in my mind so you
can start thinking about alternatives
and this is
a a paper that adrian
adrian rudder
professor in cornell lead
this
nice publication where
we advocate that part of the
lack of predictability in some of the
system has to
do with emerging behaviors
that we certainly does
not have incorp included in the crop
growth model but it's not just a
function you put in there you need to
think a bit harder than that
so part of the argument here is that all
these bar and plants that may come
compromise the yield and that's why we
don't have the predictability is due to
these bifurcations and the higher
increase your plant population the more
random this becomes
so what we are working
right now is on frameworks that help us
not only create this upward causation
again the crop growth model network that
i described think about the network and
causation all these links from let's say
trade to yield has
uh
a consequence on the uh
these emerging phenotypes again the
relationship of plant growth and kernel
number but also there's a downward
concession from competition resource
availability that need to be
incorporated
so again this is an area of active
research that we need to work out to
increase the predictability of these
models
as i mentioned before and i will
emphasize as many times as possible
there's not a lot of time to wait to
have the perfect model so even with the
information we have on the accuracies we
have we can think about using artificial
intelligence in the form of the
algorithms that i presented to provide
solutions for thinking farmers and
breeders this particular case thing is
about the
dashboard that
we can
present to to the grower
or the breeders so they can start
assessing how they're going to
prioritize food production water use and
carbon
a very trivial example here but we have
made the case is we can increase the
carbon sequester carbon production
stouring the dry matter if we increase
to upper transpiration but the question
is if we are going to do that in
nebraska pumping water from the ogallala
river that's a very dumb idea so again
now we have the breeder has the
information so they can be deliberate
about their decisions
and this give me give me a little good
segue to start thinking about how we're
going to breed for climate change and
hopefully we can finish the talk with
an example of why i think we are
in a very poor situation as we think
about breeding for climate change the
case i'm going to use again builds on
mace breathing in the united states
that's what we know and that we have a
fair amount of data so the first
condition
that has to happen is did the climate
change
concurrently with
the breathing program from from pioneer
and what we see here is
uh different variables this aggregate is
for the corn belt noaa has a beautiful
application that can give you these
aggregates of precipitation temperature
and amplitude and there's no doubt in my
mind when you look at the anomalies
relative to the
last century
the precipitation looks like it's been
increasing there's no doubt that minimum
temperatures increase and the amplitude
decreased because of maximums have not
changed that much
thing has been known from crawl in the
night late 90s and that trend seems to
be holding quite steady right now
so first condition
the climate change at this during the
same period or
that the breathing program was operating
so now you can start asking questions
how the genetic gain can change with
climate change
in the perfect world
we can do is
of
let's say from the 1930 which is the
beginning of the breeding program till
1990 we select hybrids that growers
decided that they were the best hybrids
by buying them
so that can help us select
the set of genotypes and monitoring
genetic gain so that is if you will is
the the reference set uh that we want to
uh consider to estimate genetic gain
let's say 1930 to 1990s and then what we
do
if we
has um
feel that the desires is run an
experiment from 30 years 1990 to 2020 to
assess the effect of that climate change
over the genetic gain
fortunately cortez conducted experiments
since 1990
with the same set of genotypes these are
the known as the dubique era studies
dubik conduct this until the 2000s mark
cooper run those trials till 2016.
and
when he left cotaba and i ran those
experiments until 2021 when i left
cortez so we have 30 years worth of
experiment
for which we have
the same set of genotypes all those dot
black dots is each hybrid release or
commercializing each year
for 30 years so that experiment was run
30 years in three locations in in iowa
and
because
the plant population i think about that
logistic map and chaos
you push the density too high the whole
hybrid crashes you put too low the new
hybrids don't work as well
we the same experiment have now a
management dimension to normal high and
low densities
so
for for any year in this lattice what we
can do is you can plot grain yield the
year of commercialization
and in this example you have a normal
density for the year 2000 you can
calculate the rate of genetic gain
and we can do the same thing we can
calculate all these slopes which are the
genetic gains for each year
and the low density normal density and
high density and this is what i'm
showing here and remember they're
confusing because the axis is here
commercialization to calculation again
and year of when the experiment was
conducted in this lower panel so don't
get confused on that so for the lower
panel think about these l panel l
uh 1990 to 2020 think about the rate of
genetic gain is about 2.5 pretty pretty
steady so think about that we can call
it g
as your rate of genetic gain certain
genotypes contribute to maintaining
increased yields over time
so
if you increase the plant population and
let's assume for the moment that there's
no trend in there
just by adding a management dimension
the interaction enables
the breathers to triple about that rate
of gender gain essentially it tells you
that the more hybrids can tolerate
better the density the rate of genetic
gains could be higher
if you increase the the plant population
even further now you start talking about
the genotype by by management by marine
interaction the rate of genetic gain in
the midwest is accelerating
so let me stop there for a moment before
we start thinking about uh
what may be the causes of this finding
what
one thing is for sure from all these 30
years of worth of data
is that the rate of genetic gain were
always positive over 30 years of
experimentation in the central corn belt
this is the largest crop production the
most productive system in the world
and
some question that come to mind and i
scratched my head many times and i gave
up already is why pnas published an
article saying that not genetics is
improving ills in favor of the
environment
i think this is
my mind pretty nonsense we have data
uh but anyways
uh it's
for you to
to decide
i already gave up on this one
so what i'll do is i'm going to focus on
hypotheses of why
the genetic gain is accelerating and
this is important to unravel because
if this is a general a generalized trend
then the climate change is not a problem
actually it can be changed it's
accelerating for production so we have
less of a problem if this is one
exceptional example is just for corn
then
we might have a problem with climate
change i think the big problem is we
have very little information to make any
decision and this is why i think we are
in a very poor situation in terms of how
we are going to breed for the future
so one thing is genetic gain increase
with favorable water conditions
you saw the the precipitation was
increased over time the other one is
that genetic gain increase
is due to this long-term adaptation to
lower amplitude temperatures and let me
elaborate in this two hypotheses
so first
let's go back to the key
process that is driving yield in corn
this is an experiment we run and publish
in general experimental botany
let's focus on these w1210
less stress more stress for yield this
lower left panel
black bars are the double cross think
about the old hybrids
the white bars or open bars are for the
single cross or modern hybrids so you
can see is regardless of the environment
the water environment modern hybrids are
more than the old ones and
the more severe the stress the higher
the delta so you have heterogeneous
variances in here if you look at the
energy perspective
so what happens is
you increase the stress
all hybrids crash more
they express more barrenness scatter
grain and reduce kind of numbers so what
happens what would happen is
if the
water conditions are improving in the
corn belt
essentially you have at the same time an
improvement in the environment and
improving genetics
so something that may happen here is
that
instead of accelerating this will
predict that the
rate of gender gain should be a little
bit collapsing if anything
so again uh well what can we estimate or
have a a sense for how big or which is
the magnitude of the the change there
are 100 100 millimeters of rainfall
increase in the corn belt this is a low
amount of water
it's about 30 percent of dry land
conditions so we can use this
theoretical study we conduct with
marcoopa to estimate if the average
evapotranspiration the commonwealth is
about
500 millimeters you have another 100
you can see a huge impact at least when
you look at this front which is the
best managed uh crops that uh
that that that you can uh deliver on on
the farm so
this hypothesis if anything is going
against what we think
is accelerating
the alternative hypothesis is looking at
light use efficiency there's evidence
another paper that we're waiting for
hopefully you'll get probably soon
that
selection or for yield increased
radiations efficiency about thirty
percent in one country's breeding
the other thing we know
is
that the latest efficiency is highly
correlated with the amplitude
temperature which is the one that has
been decreasing steadily over the last
hundred years
so
the argument here is
breeders has been improving
radiation insufficiency
is that it may be an improved adaptation
to this decreasing amplitude and because
this has been happening for 100 years
um what happened in let's say from the
20 to the 90s is what's really
predictive was what happened in the 90s
to 30 because it's over the same
environmental trajectory so in this
particular case the environment was
decreasing genetic is going increasing
and
hopefully we don't stay on the same
place but
i hope you can see the
[Music]
the the argument here is
what we've been selecting in the past it
was predictive of the environment that
were coming in the future and therefore
when you have that agreement the um the
correlation of performance of the old
genotypes in new environment uh you
expect to be high
so this we get to the
end of the presentation and call it
chapter 10 because it's been published
in 1996 in a wonderful chapter by mark
cooper
which is
about
breeding g by e
and the essentially the correlation or
what you expect in terms of correlation
of covariance between the selection
environment and your target population
of environment so here you can map into
these four corners what may happen when
g by e
is present in the multi-environment
trials and the
tpe so you think about the
multi-environment trials
maybe start on the
left side or left peak on this plane
orange plane look at the
met for 2020 and tpe for 2020 that's our
current breeding system
we breed for our current environment so
there's a positive covariance right
go to the opposite side if you think
okay we're going to breed for climate
change for 2050 multi-environment trials
of course you're going to have a high
correlation if we get this right
think about this corner if you were in
2030 the the multi-environment trials
that were conducted in the 20 to this
let's say 60s or 90s were predictive of
the 2020 therefore you have a high
correlation
between the two and that may explain why
the genetic gain is maintained or
accelerated the key problem here is what
if these situations start changing
where what happened if
we run multi-environment trials
mimicking 2050 environments essentially
we start breathing for climate change
today
but we test those those uh hybrids in
2020 environments if the correlation is
not good we are going to get too ahead
of us and essentially are going to
starve today's populations the opposite
if you don't start breeding from climate
change you're going to start future
populations the question is where we are
at
in the u.s corn belt
example which is the only experiment i'm
aware of we can say we are somewhere in
there essentially the pace of
environment change if it's tied to the
changes in amplitude temperature you can
expect to continue that rate of genetic
gain and you expect to continue perhaps
the acceleration
so now the question is what was going to
happen with with wheat do we have
information maybe there's one experiment
maybe in
in europe uh dubai in which is huge
what's going to happen with rice other
major crop maybe minor crops where do we
stand
in terms of breeding for these changing
climates
i will leave that uh
as an open question and hopefully uh you
will agree that yes we can think about
agricultural solution to climate change
but we desperately need a framework for
predicting for climate change to inform
policy and decisions
i think i will leave it with this nice
cartoon uh that i think we need to start
taking action pretty soon
thank you very much
any questions from the audience i know
some students might have response to
other classes
but you have many questions
[Music]
at the very end of your presentation you
were talking about
this chapter the vision 1996 and i was
wondering so that the reading
techniques and technologies have evolved
a lot since 1996
and uh to what extent we should
devote a lot of energy
for breeding for the future if we don't
know yet maybe in the future the
technologies would be so advanced
that we will be able to breed breathe
much much faster
and we should rather dedicate more
energy today so
i i'm just wondering what is your time
on that
i think the the first
bit that i think is missing is to stop
monitoring or have a sense for where we
are at with different crops as we have
that intuition for maze
uh the i think the answers are going to
be very different in regions
uh regardless of what technology you can
think about gene editing uh that may or
may not be the answer maybe we don't
need to do anything
i think the is the the lack of
where we are at
uh that we need to to solve that that to
me is the first question is develop that
nutrition for what's happening with the
other crops the second is understanding
in corn
is this acceleration will continue or is
going to
stop at some point in time
i think we are approximating in
potentials
i think this quantitative genetics-based
breeding is is extremely effective so if
we can use ai and some of the
physiological models it will help us
inform what can we do in terms of
breeding and can accelerate genetic gain
how you
what are the other technologies uh
frankly
maybe we need to start thinking about
what technology i don't think changing
one gene at the time is is going to do
it
uh there's like
20 or 30 years of
biotechnology that didn't deliver on
that ambition
so
i will
i will
focus my efforts on building upon the
framework that works which is the
quantitative genetics
um
i'm wondering uh
with respect to uh
questions like climate change but uh
just in general
to what extent can we hope that with
improved uh
breeding
we could design plants that have a
better ability to have plasticity in the
way they
respond or acclimate to various
environments
and in that way decrease the g by e
in other words
we know plants
already have an enormous capability
of changing what they do depending on
the environment that they
sense at a particular moment or a period
of time
could there be opportunities to further
improve
that kind of
uh favorable acclimation or plasticity
oh absolutely uh i think the
the best example
is coming from africa actually
uh where
the selection for
plasticity and tillering and and
prolificacy actually
uh is is leading to
um
stability ill stability
uh part of the ill stability is being
part of the criteria in mace breeding
over the last century and that's why you
don't see that much gye in my opinion
recent studies on tillering it suggests
contrary to what we thought that will be
an ill drug penalty is actually not
compromising the potential adhesion
environments that were tested
in in kansas and we are seeing exactly
the same thing in in africa at least in
south africa in pretty severe stress
environment
so
the breeders in in
in these marginal
regions
uh improved that if you will kernel set
and
the
resilient or created this plastic corn
if you will
people don't like to see the tillers but
based on our latest research it doesn't
seem to hurt and when it rains
they can adapt to that better
environment
so i think you have a
uh
my mind pretty compelling experi
evidence
from that tillering and prolificacy that
is possible to use
uh molecular breeding to accelerate and
breed for that plasticity
i think the the other question is to
look at the traits that you're going to
manipulate some in for example the
conductance
to
uh
to
to
[Music]
humidity
by large is not having to have a lot of
g by e because it's going to compensate
but if you push it to certain extremes
you might see the g by interaction
so i think this is totally possible
great thank you very much
thank you
one more question in the rule before we
go to the audience yes
so thank you very much for a great
presentation
um just to ask more about some traits
that uh are capable of maintaining
productivity in different climate change
scenarios uh here in the northeast where
the region of the continental us was the
greatest increase in extreme
precipitation events so when i think
about how climate change is going to
affect
agriculture in the northeast i think
it's not only just going to increase
precipitation but the
extreme events of precipitation so
are there any plant traits that you
think of
when bleeding
that are
able to
maintain productivity not with just more
precipitation but more extreme
precipitation
i
i don't have an answer to that
if if i need to answer that question i
will use the the models perhaps
unis is is using to develop an intuition
what may be the traits
i think that would be a really
interesting
example not only to maintain
productivity but with this extreme event
how you're going to prevent leeching and
environmental externalities
so i i would say you have maybe a more
interesting buzz on how to do both at
the same time
but
i think these are complex systems uh the
the type of uh
studies we did for this conductance
response to vpd i will
use simulation to explore develop a
nutrition for what are the traits that
may be useful
thank you so
three questions from zulu yes uh i
thought carla and
her student church
is their person and uh susan
yeah so carlos please go ahead
oh hi uh charlie fantastic talk and uh
very exciting
and i i see joshua also has a question
so i'm going to be brief because
probably he will have a question along
the same lines
we are
i'm very intrigued and excited to see
that you are
you know
combining
knowledge
in addition to data in fact i'm a big
fan of that approach i think that the
data-driven approach that everybody is
using nowadays is not going to take us
that far
and indeed a much more
uh
meaningful way is combining you know
knowledge with the data and and
incorporating as much prior knowledge as
possible so this is a bit my question
basically
and this is maybe a long question some
we'll talk
at another time but my
it sounds that you are using these
mechanistic models and maybe the main
way for the way you are incorporating
this prior knowledge is by generating
data with the models and then fitting
some kind of
model to predict
is that what you are doing
we are calculating uh some deltas
using this approximate basin computation
not not really fitting a model but we
are go we fit the marker within the
we have doing the fitting of markers
within the dynamical model yeah
yeah yeah yeah and using this bayesian
knob
it's an optimization optimization
reasoning okay yeah very good
yeah i want i would like to learn more
and maybe you can talk another time and
thanks so much again great talk
what i really would like to do is is try
your sudoku algorithm and see how he can
put the crop model
within that framework
yeah yeah so so yeah i would like to
think about it indeed
i mean the key part is how we can
develop you know
typically you know
neural networks have all these layers
that are black boxes and we like
you know using interpretable uh latent
space so that we can uh
you know condition the models better
based on prior knowledge yeah and thanks
i love the sudoku analogy because i
think that's
easier to understand than material
science so thank you for mentioning it
um
oh yeah sure so i guess uh
i'm carla student and i was also just
wondering about uh for these crop models
do they generally have a way to
incorporate
uncertainty such as like uncertainty
about the future weather or or
uncertainty about our knowledge of the
processes like there might be some
processes that are not modeled
you you can actually uh if you want to
come to florida i would love to work
with you on that
yes you can we can write it in a way
that you can
embed
uncertainty in the parameters we can put
functions and
again a hypothetical connection in the
network and then you can make it kind of
fuzzy and ask the question whether that
process exists or to what extent exists
and the future weather yes
that's that's been done uh pretty
routinely
sorry that follow-up is this
leveraging on this bayesian framework
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um
cool thank you i'll definitely take a
look and try to learn more about this
yeah send me an email and what i'm happy
to talk with you i've been trying to do
that uh but i
i need a smart student like you and
a professor like karla to get it done
thank you
okay thanks charlie it was fantastic to
have that talk and it it winds me back
around thinking about rice and
so my question for you is that
the question and then i'll explain it
the question is do you think that
hybrids
convey some kind of advantage in the
face of the challenges that we face in
the in the breeding community and the
reason i'm asking is because as you know
very well
rice is normally bred as an inbred
except in china
because it's because heterosis is not
that big an advantage for us however
in rain-fed environments where we don't
have where we don't manage the water
it seems that the hybrid
hybrids are sometimes more resilient to
the variation that we have in both
hydraulics and
you know water and temperature and other
things and so
the grain quality suffers a bit because
there's more variants okay so for the
discriminating eater
the quality isn't there
but for simply providing quality hot
carbohydrates
the hybrid might be a good solution but
i'm asking now in the specifically in
the context of climate change do you
have any reason to believe or do you
have any any priors on this to suggest
that the hybrid route might be better
than the inbred route for rice
not the rice expert by any means
but
i can
borrow information from what happened in
maze breeding and
if you look at the females
inbred
they look like hybrids so
unless you have a compelling evidence
that heterosis is a major driving of
performance
you
may get away and make faster progress
just
breathing the ingredients i
in which is the other thing right
how many years they've been trying to
find form hydraulic groups and i haven't
seen a lot of that is really compelling
so i yeah so there's so there's no
complementation
in the context of the pathways and the
manipulations of prior knowledge that we
know
that would provide an advantage for
having two alleles rather than one at
these loci
um
again i'm thinking about corn where
there's some even genomic regions
missing that that perhaps is a big part
of the heterosexual maze i don't know in
rice
anyway i'll leave it as a question i
think it's it's one that
for for the rice community is quite
compelling
because the changes that we have to
breed for include
emerging from the irrigated system
with very very different root structures
and all kinds of things so
it'd be fun to see what the parallels
will bring i remember a conversation
with duvek many years ago
and he said once we get rid of the
deleterious process we're gonna we're
gonna be modeling just like you guys
meaning an inbred so maybe your answer
sort of reflects that
yeah it's good
thanks
from
advancer's group how much
does impress the guy
[Music]
i don't know
all my experience was in in hybrids and
every time we tried to predict
hybrid from ingredients was not a very
successful endeavor
in may
i don't know ed
yeah
charlie i think that that's going back
to susan's question that i think
you know yes i agree those inbreds look
great but i only ever see those inbreds
under good environmental
conditions if if we put them under the
same g by e stress i wonder
if we'd see you know something different
and you know
that there is buff there is
environmental range buffering uh there
and you know for wheat people out there
this is i think with the d there's an
argument the d genome is that
environmental buffer oh okay
i think it's something we we should be
asking and we could ask it using the
maze inwards but we haven't probably
okay thanks
hey
maybe the question for you susan and ed
and
going back one time
i think we need a framework and start
organizing this views for breathing for
climate change because otherwise we end
up with what is the ideotype rather than
how we are going to
breed
today for tomorrow for 2030 without
starving populations until we get the
final answer
and
from what i've been reading is
i don't think breeders were involved
enough
to define that path
so
if you're interested i
would like to spend more time on that
and i think the the ai with color is
part of the means to get to that
accelerated reading
i think it's definitely worth
conversations and it might be worth uh a
panel or a or a you know some kind of
workshop
just to list the questions and organize
our our thinking if we could combine
inbred and hybrid
you know species if you will and
breeding approaches i think it's it's
kind of an important opportunity
because all i even hear of course you
know there's potatoes going forward to
breed hybrids based on inbreed inbred
diploids so people are doing somersaults
in the air to try to come down on their
feet these days and willing to try
anything
yeah i hear potato is not
the fastest
they'll be growing potatoes from what
the 30s
at least in florida
thank you very much for everyone joining
us
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu